[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kevin james is starring in a netflix
movie an adam sandler movie and uh it's
based on sean payton's one-year
sabbatical from the nfl he was suspended
goes back to his hometown to coach his
son's pop warner team kevin james plays
the role of sean payton v sean payton
the saints head coach joins us on the
program
did you have any say in who was going to
uh portray you coach
i didn't i appreciate i appreciate the
pitch but this was uh
yeah this was done
uh
kind of uh with adam sandler's group and
uh
my daughter had done a little where are
they now piece for nfl network
oh
a couple years ago
and it was about that sixth grade team
and seven or eight players and the story
that season and
i think it was condensed into maybe a
five minute hit on network and adam
saw it
and um
asked his brother-in-law my my
daughter's boyfriend chris
to uh he said write that movie
and that was kind of a big deal
for chris and
you know adam doesn't say that all the
time and long story short you know here
we are
um
i'm sure adam and uh kevin and the rest
of them from happy madison you know kind
of re you know looked at it and made
their adjustments
so i've kind of been a just a bystander
from afar and uh i'm i'm sure it'll be
um
more of the humorous tone and uh
yeah i think certain movies repeat
themselves like that you know whether
it's the bad news bears or the mighty
giants or the
the ducks or you know what i mean the
storyline yeah but but do you have sk
do you have script approval
oh yeah i i read through it the whole
thing yes and
basically
um there's some parts in there that
that are they're definitely funny and in
in part of the movie
um
and more importantly to me
was
my ex-wife beth's thoughts and my son
and my daughter all the people around me
you know when you get
to where you're 57 you're not as worried
about what other people think but i
wanted to make sure that my children and
beth felt good about it
uh
you know it's kind of interesting though
when you when you have it based on your
life but i'm wondering in real life
what did you learn about yourself when
you got suspended that year
well
i would say there were two things you
know you you the first month
you know you're livid you're angry you
you i'm gonna call it a sham
um and try to be kind but you go through
that like you can't believe
the way it unfolded and and what was
being said or portrayed by by the league
office and
and then secondly you're like man this
is going to be a long year if you
continue to wake up feeling like this
you know in other words and so then you
go through maybe there's three stages
that you know the next stages you begin
to
all right what are we going to do here
and
um
i had recovered from an injury that
happened actually in tampa bay on the
sideline and so i began working out
quite a bit ran a half marathon
i mean training like daily
and then
coaching this team or being i was an
assistant i wasn't the head coach i was
the offensive coordinator
of the sixth grade team that had not
really had any success
and
here's the thing though it's
this sounds crazy
but it's it's still the same you're
teaching
there's a dynamic that you you want to
communicate a subject matter
and you got to figure out what wins
and then you got to figure out how to do
that to win
and then you start winning and then the
players believe and then you win some
more and then they have confidence and
and it's the same with the sixth grade
team as it is with an nfl team
did you show them your resume
i mean you didn't get the head coaching
job you only an oc so
pretty tough i i didn't want listen i
didn't want to deal with the parents
number one
[Laughter]
would you rather deal i'm not going to
deal with any parents would you rather
deal with the media or parents
the media
the media
i've gone honestly and the parents were
great but i've gone
to a number of high school games because
my son played high school football and
i'm amazed
i'm amazed
in awe
or in shock of the behavior or
cluelessness that i observe
in the bleachers i i it's just
and i don't know if it's the parents
trying to live vicariously through their
children or not maybe understanding or
or really failing to realize that the
bigger picture which is
just the growth
of their child's education and i'm not
talking about just sports it could be
um the band for a gal it could be art
it's just part of like growing up and
look there's a few that i understand
that they go on maybe in play in college
and then maybe i don't discount any of
that but just
the some of the behavior or attitudes
that that you observe or you just cringe
but
no i would choose the media every day
over um
the the parents and uh
that was part of the deal i didn't have
to visit with parents about why johnny
or billy wasn't playing or anything like
that saint said coach sean payton at the
eagles on sunday thanksgiving uh hosting
the bills and then you host the cowboys
you're coming off back-to-back losses
how long does it take to put a loss to
the side and move on
i would say generally speaking you know
there's that 24 hour maybe a little bit
longer um
maybe a day and a half or so depending
this this one this past weekend
um
i don't know that i'll ever get over it
you know in other words just the
the way
the way the game unfolded how we wanted
to play it and then
you know to have some of the
things take place that took place um
it's just
it's tough it's tough because you you
dive into a week
with you know your total preparation and
and i think um
man i think we just in a lot of ways uh
if we've seen it happen each weekend
with the officiating and and
it that's the that's the hardest thing
to get past is
you know when when they're not up to
speed maybe or or or
it happened to the bears you know a week
a week and a half ago
yeah and i don't know if you've watched
yourself on the sidelines the reaction
in that game but
if they were thought bubbles i'd love to
know what you were thinking
i think though
look i honestly i can recall a little
bit of it
and
i think in in you know
back it 10 years ago i'd have been i
think it was i was i may have been
thinking that but i was i think a little
bit calmer
and just i hate getting to the point
where it's expected we're like you're
numb
and
but those kind of things can't happen
you know i mean they just
and and
and i look at that more uh
from an overall leadership perspective
and training perspective and like that
those problems start at the top not at
the individual cruise
yeah
yeah i think you know somehow we got to
reduce the variables but can you talk to
the league about that do you do they let
let you have a voice
um yeah look i was part of the
competition committee for a while and uh
and so
it's just
it's it's something that i know
uh other head coaches and general
managers i know most
in this profession
uh
believe in certain things and to help
that change
and
i look i know there's
a number of people in our positions that
believe these guys should be full-time i
mean i
that they should be coming back monday
in in in centralized locations how are
17 crews ever going to be on the same
page when
um when there's a conference call or
zoom call and then
you know that but that's for that's for
another day right now but coach you know
the stakes are too high you know with
what's going on with gambling i mean
this is big business we know that
um the nfl can afford full-time
officials
i listen i would agree with you
i would agree with you don't you want to
say to the betting public we we
you know we're taking this seriously we
have to
we have to improve
yes like we have to
and and look everyone everyone watching
and participating in involved in it
deserves better
how close did you come to getting obj
uh
um
i thought look we had good conversations
he's from here i thought
only he could answer that but i thought
uh i felt real positive i you're in the
middle of game week so you're preparing
for another game and look
if he's truly interested in coming
here's our pitch here's what we think
here you know and then at that point
you know he can sort through that and we
had several conversations i i would say
close i the question would be i all
along if la had an opportunity i knew
that's where he was going to go
and i don't think los angeles really was
an option until like maybe middle of the
process
um
yeah i would say
fairly close but i think only he would
be able to answer that
i wonder if drew brees was still your
quarterback would you have
would you have landed him
i think
i think la i'm meaning that
sometimes matters scenarios okay
i think yeah i believe that
yeah i i was just wondering about that
that you know you could
have him come back home and he can be
the featured wide receiver like i don't
know what you is this like your
recruiting pitch
as if you were a college coach when
you're trying to get somebody
well i i think in a in a very small like
micro i mean just in a very small quick
two-day process i think this ultimately
and i can you know in recruiting for
instance there are certain
bullet point
things that you need who are the
decision makers what's most important
and i think la was important more than i
think los angeles was important for him
and
and i think that i get it
where do you stand on the taunting rule
i think it's i think it's being over
officiated i sat in on like
the the discussions i think i don't
think any of us that
discussed it saw it where it is now
who was asking for it coach because i
didn't know that it was you know this uh
real dilemma that this is a big problem
in the nfl with yeah look i think
here's but in fairness to that question
it's like anything else the lines got to
be eventually bright you know when you
start having players stand over players
you know crawl over players with their
crotch that
there's there's got to be
like hey if if if you and i watch a game
and we say just sit next to each other
and turn to each other and we say
taunting that's probably a taunting foul
you with me yeah
and and we would see it and think ah
that's that's too much like you can't do
that
um
but i think then
therein lies the challenge of
communication as to hey this is
i'm going to show you 50 clips and you
tell me which ones you think should be
called taunting and it's no different
than
roughing the passer
that's so what's the first word
and it's roughing and so if i turn to
you and we watch the game i i think we'd
be able to say that's probably roughing
but i don't like the word roughing the
passer because if i graze your helmet i
didn't rough you
and and i why can't that be a five-yard
attempt i like the word roughing i like
the word roughing why all right and i
don't want to call anything if i graze
anyone in football oh okay but they do
[Laughter]
all right let's let's go all the way
back to the shoots and ladders we're
back at the very
very beginning of the discussion
i don't want you to get fined coach
no i won't i
won't how much have you been well you
lost a whole salary
but except for that how many times have
you been fined by the league off by the
way i think once why didn't i never
understood that and i know it's not my
money but i like
man you gotta i would have been livid
like you're gonna take a salary away
from me the whole season like i'm mad on
your behalf you're you're over it maybe
that was
that was well not ever that was the
first two months that we talked about
before man
you know it was the
the the anger and it was look it was it
was done it was done it was a way to try
to circumvent really what the rules
uh at that time were and that's it's 500
000 at that time for a league employee
but
um
oh
that's a lot of money
how about we talk about your team how's
your team doing coach going into this
game again
i've never been able to come on the dan
patrick show and for a brief moment via
telephone feel like i made him like
awkward or uncomfortable and i just felt
like i did that so team's doing good
we're banged up a little bit we go to
philly
we do have this
unique
thursday
not thursday night game but it's it's
unusual we play thursday night
thanksgiving and then we flip around and
play again home thursday versus the
cowboys so so we're gonna see
the eagles and we're gonna see the bills
and we're gonna see the cowboys um
and
i don't know that's like what three
games and however many days but uh so i
think part of his being the head coach
is just being smart relative to how much
time we're on our feet and how to manage
the practice schedule those type things
what do you what do you do against tom
brady that other coaches don't do why
why are you successful against brady
i look i i think this number one i think
we have a good defense
but you know what i mean i think
and
if you have a good defense then i think
then
um
you know that's part of it it's a
hard-fought game we
unfortunately we weren't in the playoff
game and
i think there are a lot of things that
go into winning
and if you're playing him and you're
turning the ball over at midfield you're
going to pay if you're playing him and
you're not capitalized you know like
almost like there's not going to be
these
errors that sometimes you get
when you're playing another player at
that position and certainly that you
know a player that
that our league's never seen at that
position so
your margin for error has to be sharp
and and i think defense you have to have
a good defense i mean i think that
look if you go back and remember
the tampa game in new england and it was
the return and the rebirth and holy cow
all right i mean it was it was
unbelievable that
the the
the media attention to that game
and
man new england has got a good defense
and
that game was
i think down to the you know final score
yeah with the rookie quarterback and so
i i do think it starts with you know
obviously a good defensive plan and
understanding maybe some of the basic
principles of how to win and not how to
lose
i still think back when i think of
drafts and you told us that you know hey
we were trading up we were we wanted or
we were going to get mahomes
and uh and then you you ended up taking
lattimore who's obviously a very good
player but just that what is that well
we didn't know at the time so i don't
know if you were like crushed we're like
we got mahomes and then you don't have
mahomes and and
what's that feeling like when you don't
get him at that time
at the time
at the time realistically you have a
small bubble there we're picking 11.
and so this is i think what happens in a
lot of draft rooms you have
yet you have to have
at least as many players in the bubble
as there are picks or you don't have a
pick like you have to like
and i knew it was lattimore and homes in
this cloud
and there were three picks left
before it was our pick so
you're getting to a spot where when
there's two picks left and you have two
and you're
you you're getting one of your guys
and so
lattimore we didn't think
was going to be available
and here here was here was the the the
question in a nutshell it was help your
team now with the corner while you have
drew or
help your team
long term
with with the quarterback
and
we were we were once
pick nine was made we knew we had one of
the two
one of the two choices
and i don't know if pic 10 was someone
else what we would have done at 11. we
were discussing you know back and forth
about the qb in the corner
and then
so at the time when something like that
happens
there are times where you're just like
uh you had one guy someone stepped up
took your guy and you just you're
dejected or you know i've seen that
happen
but i think the feeling
was when andy when the chiefs went to 10
i knew right away it was going to be for
patrick
and then
we knew
we were getting lattimore yeah
so there there wasn't a room of
like
ejection or it was it was kind of high
fives like man we just we had no idea we
thought this corner would slip and he
ended up being the rookie of the year
but
it's funny how
those things can happen
you know and in
after working him out in in
uh in college we like we crept out of
town we got on the owner's plane we
didn't take let anyone see us it was a
private workout
uh it was it was that
it was that good
i'm talking about patrick yeah
yeah
well
yeah you just you know these draft day
things i remember the cowboys i thought
they were going to take johnny manziel
and i'm like oh my god you know because
jerry's going to get involved in this i
remember oh yep yep yep i remember oh
man
right right
well here's the thing
the the funny thing about all of that
the funny thing about all of that what
was the year draft day came out
oh the costner movie
uh paulie googled it
2014 movie came out 2014. all right
what was the manziel draft
2012.
has it been that long
2012.
oh no
no it's same year coach 2014. same year
that's what i thought
so
in in in the movie
in the movie
i think the browns go with
the the scout the costner graded player
as opposed to and in real life
they passed on bill wallace they put
passed on bo wallace and they took uh
mac the linebacker
right and you recall they tested bo
wallace and you know they had all these
little things if you turn to page 48 you
see this
send it back to us and they knew he
didn't look at the playbook and they
worried about his leadership blah blah
blah and then in real life
[Laughter]
was was manziel beau wallace
now listen i i remember a little bit i
i
i wasn't a part of the manziel draft
what was manziel's year it was his 12th
season
yes i remember i was coming back from
suspension and look i followed his
season it was magnificent i've spent
time with johnny
um actually discussed and spent some
time about bringing them in here for
you know this was years ago um
when the super bowl was in houston
and uh and so i i think look
we root for guys
like we root for like all right what's
the best thing he can do and let's do
those things with him and let's see him
have success we we root for players we
don't root against
and so
yeah but i i just thought there was some
irony the the the movie the cleveland
browns
i mean it was it
it was uh
it was right at the same time
hey uh it's great to talk to you as
always we appreciate when you join us
and i hope there's no sequel to this
movie because that means you get
suspended again so uh
[Laughter]
wait you're not laughing i i i hope i
hope there's most people as well
thank you coach appreciate your time all
right dan i appreciate your friendship
sean payton saints head coach